uh-huh it's just like Undercover Brother
they're gonna use this catchy music to
make you buy all those wings you're
you're finally learning let's get it
yeah the brainwashing you become more
well-versed culturally totally you know
I do is my job as a white guy hello
there reject nation Greg Alba John
Humphrey we're gonna watch some BTS
blood sweat and tears official music
video so at our patreon one of our top
reward tiers is whatever video you
request reaction or discussion we must
definitely do them put up on the
youtubes and today is a request from
Natalie Dharan Natalie loves BTS pretty
much introduced me and also our patreon
we do exclusive content and one of our
main things that we do primarily hosted
by this cat Jon music video reaction see
on YouTube a lot of time in order to at
least get it visible we have to cut up
the reactions over there is plenty of
uncut music video reactions that I
occasionally guest in but mainly this
guy Justin solo so if you love his white
face and those pearly eyes and that big
get a mock up go check it out over there
they don't have fun in real life it's
too much work so highly prepared they
all hate themselves they hate one
attention
I had no idea they wrote this piece
there the paintings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh damn
first I want to do with it
[Music]
[Music]
we called in you
[Music]
kinky
looking at me looking at me we're
singing to you I I think you're seducing
me they're doing a lot more I need it
[Music]
you know you could tie me up
they're making me ties make it mean come
to my senses I'll let everyone know we
made it
talking about Indiana Jones yeah
[Music]
laser focus
whoa whoa they're becoming the paintings
John
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she
the chocolate wings yeah looky there
break off pieces
[Music]
whoo whoa damn I thought about it I
don't think it's about them trying to
have sex with me what what was your
first what was your first hint well I
think he was trying to have sex from the
statue
oh yeah yeah chocolate wings but but but
couldn't you be the stand-in for the set
I couldn't the statue with its blank
features beat all of us designed for us
to project ourselves on - this is very
objective and then this is open to
interpretation so very direct about I'm
talking about I'm really bad at this
clearly the lead singer BTS is obsessed
with real-life buffalo chocolate wings
that sounds like it could be disgusting
or surprisingly good cuz you know how
like Mexican cocoa spicy spice sure
that's what he's referring yeah this is
a size like The Weird Al of kpop he's
just singing about food look as an
American who has rarely traveled outside
of California I know plenty about Korean
culture yeah if you want to know like
well the deeper meaning behind
everything in a completely non offensive
non sarcastic way I'm rego to God oh
yeah and I'm telling you Tyson Buffalo
chocolates that's right this is all a
tool for the big chicken chocolate kpop
and chocolate waiting special interests
yeah that's a pretty groovy song now
just think the song be on the video oh
well I'm pretty sure he was trying to
have sex with me one might suspect if
you didn't look close enough you can
miss that but yeah that's the message
here I don't put some ID
but in all seriousness if there's any
left the interpretation I have is just
being tempted at a very lustful way by
I'm not sure like in my mind I'm like oh
is he talking about the devil being
tempted by something like that but and
all I'll say like the chocolate winged
thing sounds like something being really
sweet and appetizing like all these evil
things that are within him so he's
talking about like surrendering his soul
to something cold surrendering or not
him but he knows that rule then the
voice of the song yeah they're talking
about surrendering into something and
they're talking about dying and giving
into something that they're very much
tempted by and then here it's like at
the very end it looks like he sold his
soul yeah and that's the main thing is I
don't give it all my blood sweat and
tears yeah and I feel like you can take
that in a couple different directions
because there's a lot that you could
draw in just what they do in general you
know chasing this dream have this sort
of obsessive well they're never gonna
make it no I don't think they will I
mean especially if they keep pushing out
stuff like this you know they really
step up leg this isn't modern enough
this is a modern not putting able I
don't understand it I don't know if
that's part of the actual song or one of
those music video things yeah we're
saying he too was a tempter and stuff
yeah you know Liam break into actors
like a scene I actually really liked it
it's easy to get caught up in the
visuals of a BTS video oh yeah cuz
they're always a dance yeah and they
also have like crazy visual flair with
the direction and the editing that I
always sit back and try to like what's
the lyrics about exactly I'm always
fascinated by that note oh and I think
lyrically speaking this is my favorite
of theirs
okay lyrically speaking yeah no I I
especially after reading the translation
and stuff I I appreciated it too and I
think they can work on that other side
to where it just part of it seemed to me
like just an expression of longing for
some kind of love or whatever that is
dysfunctional or toxic or not good for
you but that you just longed for anyway
I feel like across at least the songs
I've heard there is kind of a note of
picked
a time or two about like a doom during
unrequited love that just really
consumes you and even though you know
it's not necessarily good for you or
good to indulge in you just you know
want it's a yes for it yeah it's sort of
heart wants what it wants regardless
kind of thing yeah and and also I mean
just these dudes can move man maybe
they're so like laser lock in sync with
each other like that all right yeah you
know we could do that yeah if we just
spend 16 hours a day dancing and I'm
singing on treadmills the Xbox Kinect
has a game called dance central which
I'm great at amazing at it and I feel
like if I just played a little bit
longer I'd be on their level oh yeah
definitely that's that's actually how
they started this band was they all just
used to meet and play down control then
when they just continued that game they
were like exercise trained good diet
chocolate Buffalo and comment below can
he actually play that organ because mad
respect like the one thing about these
kinds of groups I don't usually ponder
honor or assume it's always brought up
about like oh do they play instruments
or not not that they have to but it's
always like a neat thing one of them
they do and I know that these guys are
heavily involved in the construction of
their own music so if that is actually
the case then it's like oh cool then you
know I can kind of see where maybe parts
of this song came from I doubt they can
play any music I don't think that's
really them scene yeah that's pretty
sure that is the same person who fills
in for Britney Spears definitely on all
of their voices yeah all you got to do
is pitch modulate a little bit you know
make one a little higher one a little
lower its auto-tune throw a little
attack or release on something yeah yeah
I hear the BTS fans can be very
sensitive so I'm really trying to be
mindful and only lead with facts yeah
definitely you've done a great job I
want to congratulate you right now
because I don't think I could have done
this without you hey man look I do have
plenty of research on this this group
yeah band you know all the bangtan boys
equal the what bangtan boys man the
bangtan boys
that's the other thing that they're
called I know yeah
oh you were trying to confuse me that
was reverse psychology you were trying
to test me to make me think that I said
something wrong yeah dude you're a pro
at this right and your master you should
host the music videos thing so us before
wrap this up wish you occasion of the
day shots in Natalie Doran now Natalie
listen I'm gonna keep this very blunt
you've been one of our top players for a
long time you're a beautiful woman who
has introduced us to this amazing group
Bing ten Ben 10 Ben 10 boys that's what
they really did they would get together
and watch Ben 10 that would bent in my
left ear they're like we got to keep it
alive
I imagine that you probably just
constantly touch yourself to these music
videos Vinge watch all day
they are dreamy and the music is pulsing
it's okay I don't blame you I was about
to start then I remembered oh crap
there's a camera and Jon's here oh
thanks for the cameraman me first
thanks for not louis c.k me whoa whoa
outdated joke but Natalie I hope you
continue to pleasure or so VCA if they
bring you that much joy just indulge in
it just his elves because how upset
could you possibly be in your life in
that state you're Irish orgasms quite
good there so sorry how many people from
across the world can we get totally yeah
this will be the first show that you try
to hide from all your friends well you
know there's been a long time where you
just don't want to make any kind of
sexual base joke around women
and I was like screw it let's go for one
and I think it was a little too extreme
hopefully you stay pledged and hopefully
like most people you didn't watch yeah
no Natalie clicks off there's 30 you
guys can subscribe or the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
John out on patreon where you can touch
yourself to this man who has chocolate
balls
I got a dark chocolate